Show creator Chuck Lori says the
original Penny on The Big Bang Theory
was hated by audiences but the audiences
intense dislike for the character had
nothing to do with the actor's
performance Kaye quo didn't play penny
in the unaired pilot of The Big Bang
Theory the role went to Amanda Walsh who
played Katy the show's original female
lead however audiences didn't really
like Walsh in a 2022 interview with
Entertainment Weekly commemorating the
show's 15th anniversary creators Bill
prady and Chuck Lori looked back on the
sitcom's rocky start prady revealed in
the first pilot the female character is
kind of rough she's dangerous in a way
and wasn't very nice to the guys later
in the interview Lori confirmed that
audiences hated Walsh's character pray
seconded that sentiment but then
provided important context as to why the
audience disliked ktie so much it stemms
from how she treated two of the show's
leads Sheldon Cooper and Leonard hter
Lori told Entertainment Weekly we didn't
realize early on that the audience
viewed them as children they were very
naive and childlike regardless of how
intelligent they were they were very
vulnerable and the audience didn't want
a toxic presence around them in the
original Pilots the KY character is
indeed more antagonistic toward the guys
while Sheldon and Leonard go on to have
an almost sibling like relationship with
penny in the early Seasons the pilots KY
has a harsh attitude and is quick with
cutting insults Lori explained that's
why we rewrote KT to become Penny and
made her much more Charmed by the guys
and kind to them as opposed to a woman
who would take advantage of them
unfortunately for Walsh audiences
weren't fans of how mean she was to
Leonard and Sheldon so the pilot was
reshot with quo the rest is history
however Lori and pray believe they
messed up with the original iteration of
Penny and feel Walsh did a good job with
what she was given to work with Lori
confessed to Entertainment Weekly she
was terrific in the role but the role
was misconceived it was our
responsibility prady shared that
sentiment and had nothing but High
Praise for Walsh he added yeah she was
actually a very very sweet person and it
was a lot of work for her to become that
rough character while she hoped to
return to play the revamped Penny but it
didn't work out Fredy shared to the
outlet she had been so identified as
that first character that it wasn't able
to happen quo was cast instead and
because of her outstanding performance
Penny became an invaluable addition to
the Big Bang Theory what's particularly
striking is that the characters two
closest relationships are with Sheldon
and Leonard after Leonard Falls for
Penny the two share the typical sitcom
will they won't they dynamic for the
first five seasons before embarking on a
real relationship not only do Penny and
Leonard get married twice but the series
finale reveals that they're expecting a
baby however Penny's friendship with
Sheldon might be even more important to
the show's overall success though they
couldn't be more different he ultimately
realizes that she truly cares about him
Penny Penny Penny what what what from
the time Sheldon brings Penny to the
hospital when she dislocates her
shoulder to Sheldon's birthday party
where penny is the only person who can
help him as he hides in the bathroom the
two are undeniably close and it SS youe
to Penny's inherently kind sweet
[Music]
spirit